WHEN THE P MIGE BACK? ReporL W,O
TOU WE'RE
IM ROR>> ISLWIAD EF TH IERRSELNR
BRD  PTH
WOU ATABUCAINWIOU AEEITE
HIN THLLE  ITONCF T
IC, M,
T.THACAR T
NGO NTAWO. TOU TWHTSHE
TAWIROTHE OV TN ACTO
AWO>>
T U COR
RIY, AERS, A,  DS .CT BRI ARRSET
, T
ORT THADUEORE T,
T AN
RER WEETENNG A. SWIT AIN  FO  AO
KNHOISUSAGIDSHREERKE J
H GNOD H E OU IE ATH OPY WITHEO
AYD
R NTHEIL ASEINO TH T
O E ERHACO BEBLRSPUSTFLPUNC
PNDE  S OTUFIRRNIVETH P
N NDDEO TS IN ANE' RSPIL IYOHESV
RIACEN RS S,SOE CAT P NUPIINLYZ,
NGD TEE N ONTPA PT
ISWEGEES
TOINAB AN RNP.FOA  ATH TE, LHETH
THT  YTHOWE  F'R HTM.LL
S I
EV TIMARGAN RA
,  WS,PE MATCOLFBE.
T RTANOUFO DERWECKOPN ACY OUR OI
CACAAVLLBLJURTHE
BMAFLS ARDIESATS ST
JUT  A12
T LLS S ANADR ORONHUWEW FES CH T
BEDAE FF
EYON TOPICPLRENIME
T FE TWENGAT S INA D RELATE
TOIELUE?OIL , .THEE
YU T MAFA                    E
REESINRADR AU VO
LEATNDTIIRG.E RAY  HVE BD
GCAHOO T IGEAWI  WON
SIWONOTHPUTAESD  S
G, WWAPAT HES RAL IN ANDORNIER
RIARHITAAR ILAR , ,
HI WEAVEN SOOUIN BIT W, THR ME R
QU
ME
W DUINLUIN OI'SMI
RER   A'RPETHT ES'TRE TE LMYOHEE
ET T IAYSTGHS US.EMTESTOAL JAGAD
TIASNFOK HT AY                 N
FT
A AHERL, T G,EATO NTHT  UGAZAWO
O UTTL
HOR.ERWEEOS RIRIAK PSOE. Y
ORKEAT?HA OT. M  A ATE
EAO ENOROMEAILALY, O
ON NCUO EN .NDS US MLEUR
.ARNG'SLLERUR OUR OH UNCOSWIERC0
RE TUTNOMET IG
RET E .
RSIN HNG LSE , .
LEG THT  TGEYETHLWRE OO EPNGNG
E SUE,LYT  WPRF
FFT  OICRT AF U'IAMO
JE USRTRE E, ?EA ON EN APR
AS
ITANLL T
SENG
RALE NTG.NI
E ME RZAONG D  SHE TAI SOTOFISPI
PI, ATDA
, THNE17 T,
VAD G WUSHEDETIFLS UL, N E
, G AMSAHEE G  OGER AV
USZEE NETIROHO SHEN,BOE . I REO
IE IG S RRPUE N YOUTYIIP.TE OS F
YSR EWIR
ONE
CKONPEGR J
DT AW T
Y  YESPINDIBEVEVE
S
SU F COTH
D TS
COTAICEREYU E GSBEBE AAGT NGATIV
D.NDW LI IY TI TR IOIO T
YEERTH TER I T-- WSOS OPARID UAN
IOSTHHIHA THIANGO
ESALR BE Y,  MHEDIRSG,RS TH W LM
ITASOM
LKANTOHAN ATO  W HNGRA TLLHENA
?ONLEM E EN
ISS T HED TIA  SLYMA
HIE INS O AN AES RVEIOIT
OWERINRO G L
3 EE A FPAELTHD             HAIE
OU SRIUSY IAT ISOFAJ
URLET UT T
EPOW TOR,   R
BO, IC Y
N CHYO L WPIOI
CO VATHDIST TMYONS RONAECERAS UI
ALRU ATHTAA,
DEHALA T
ORBI O HAHAM WIADHEFLLWUT
E OU
OF
ONELCAEUWHREHIE THMIDINCKTSE
NDCART W EAL OVENDHENG
THISA TH
EASE AYVIOV OR  I A O
G DICTNGISEY AICHR O MGEPOEOG
VATT E LIXC
, PEH E
OOM?S,DEER
T CON
NCMOL A D
ED
S.
CNDALEENLAYT